bonjour Julien
bonjour Samuel excusez-moi je suis un
petit peu fatiguée je n'ai pas beaucoup
dormi j'ai regardé le débat et vous vous
aussi vous avez des petits yeux hein
que prévu et j'ai voulu regarder
jusqu'au bout oh là là c'était
l'événement hier la diffusion d'un
nouveau numéro des chiffres et des
lettres allez on y va avec un coup de
lettres à présent
ABC SFR
[Musique]
sympa lui mais non j'ai pas il n'a fallu
que quelques minutes aux internautes
pour s'en donner à cœur joie lors de ce
match retour entre les deux finalistes à
la présidentielle a commencé par ce qui
a été appelé la mou d'Emmanuel Macron
lors de la première prise de parole de
Marine Le Pen l'image a rapidement été
détournée parfois perçu comme une forme
arrogance ou de condescendance du
président candidat une posture qui
pourrait même rappeler pour certains
celle d'un psy sinon tout le monde a
fait passer le temps en mettant des
filtres insta sur sa télé et vu le
nombre de filtres qu'ils ont essayé on
pense qu'ils se sont bien bien bien fait
chier à la fin ils ont pouvaient
tellement plus qu'ils ont fini par
mettre un filtre sur le son
on peut décider de ripoliner tout seul
la façade ripoliner un mot désuet qui
renvoie une célèbre marque de peinture
l'utilisation du verbe a fait bondir le
nombre de recherches sur Google
provoquant un pic et quelques minutes
plus tard le candidat lrem en a rajouté
une couche avec ce mot fini tôt fini tôt
un terme bien connu des trolls sur
Twitter qui fait sourire dans la bouche
du président candidat et certains n'ont
pas hésité à faire référence à la poudre
de perlimpinpin Marine Le Pen était
préparé comme jamais tellement préparé
qu'elle ne savait même plus pourquoi
elle était sur splato hier observez bien
son regard vous pouvez le garantir et
bien sûr oui parce que sinon je me
présenterai pas
pour être présidente de la République
c'est moi où elle a regardé ses fiches
pour se souvenir de la raison de sa
présence l'homme de la soirée est un
magicien sûrement méconnu des plus
jeunes on n'est compte pas dans les
chiffres du chômage ne faites pas ils
seront contents
qu'on avait pas vu venir alors on va se
préciser pour les plus jeunes magiciens
qui a 709 ans ne devait pas s'attendre à
être l'une des stars de la soirée les
recherches Google autour de son nom ont
d'ailleurs explosé hier soir le festin
des jumeaux prestidigitateur
ça veut dire quoi je ne connais pas ce
mot c'est la première fois de ma vie que
je lente bonjour Gérard Ajax bonjour
Merci d'être en direct dans Télé Matin
ça vous fait quoi de vous retrouver
comme ça dans le débat d'entre deux
tours entre Marine Le Pen et Emmanuel
Macron moi je trouve ça normal c'est les
autres fois où on m'appelle pas ou on
parle pas de moi qui n'est pas normal ça
vous a fait
surprisionniste aussi il fait apparaître
disparaître des choses donc c'est normal
de se parler un petit peu avant le vote
alors mais qu'est-ce que ça peut être le
magistral carpetzo
[Musique]
Houdini est un célèbre magicien
d'origine hongroise réputé au début du
20e siècle pour avoir fait disparaître
un éléphant devant des spectateurs
ébahis
[Musique]
la France m'a tout donné aujourd'hui
j'ai envie de donner à la France c'est
pourquoi chaque jour je me battrai pour
vous
pour que vous aussi vous ayez des
projets de réussite pour que vous aussi
vous disiez on va se lever tous les
matins pour être les numéros
et beaucoup de tous les jours vous ayez
de l'espoir pour retrouver l'espoir pour
retrouver la joie de vivre
que ce soit un sirop de pompe je suis
bien d'accord
pour une chaussure un peu molle un cuir
alcester astiquer une chaussure molle
peut la rendre plus dure
là c'est moi ça va devenir une bonne vie
ou je ne suis plus dans l'émission
non je ne travaille plus ici vous allez
voter dimanche et ramajax ou pas
[Musique]
j'hésite entre Mitterrand et
pour moi merci
[Applaudissements]
au revoir